hola gente buena les traemos un episodio
ustedes pidieron mucho este tema
gracias jasmine rubio ahora disfruten en
tejas todo esa abstinencia abstinencia
en clase de salud dicen no tengan sexo
es difícil el miedo de todo chico es
embarazar a su novia y aveces se vuelve
real
jubilee presenta
spectrum invitamos a 5 madres
adolescentes para ver sus creencias y
valores
considere tener un aborto 321 ahora
lo que pensaba era tendré un aborto iré
a planned parenthood al final solo
cuando iba a hacerlo me di cuenta que no
sería capaz de entiendo como otros
necesitan tomar esa decisión pero si de
verdad lo considere me puse a pensar en
las mujeres en mi vida que han tenido
hijos a mi primero me vino a la mente mi
mamá se esfuerzo tanto en tener un bebé
que si yo hubiese tenido un aborto tras
eso es como si despreciar a el esfuerzo
que hizo así que dije bien voy a tener
el bebé y entonces redujo al hogar en
adopción no seré una mamá planea mi
embarazo algunos pueden pensar que no es
verdad y solo pensar y ya dice eso
porque no quiere que otros sepan fue un
accidente no puedo elegir por otros cada
quien toma sus decisiones pero hay
tantas formas para prevenir un embarazo
podías hacerlo antes en vez de cuando el
bebé ya esté ahí dentro y acabar con una
vida porque su corazón late a la cuarta
semana y usualmente es cuando se enteran
que están embarazadas no puedo tomar las
decisiones por otros
todos son libres de elegir pero
personalmente estoy en contra
me educaron sobre métodos
anticonceptivos antes de quedar
embarazada
eso me sucedió a mí pues crecí con una
familia muy cristiana así que siempre
fomentan la abstinencia y mis padres ni
siquiera sabían que yo estaba teniendo
sexo y estaba usando condones pero claro
que fui muy ingenua pensando que
funcionaría siempre loco él no hace si
sabía que había otras opciones pero era
algo que nadie nunca me explico a mí que
puedo usar esto para no embarazarme soy
de texas y en texas todo esa abstinencia
abstinencia en clase de salud dicen no
tenga el sexo y yo no sabía que un
embarazo era algo tan común pensé que
sucedía a veces cuando tienes sexo lo
que podría suceder de verdad creo que
deben enseñarlo y ser obligatorio en las
escuelas desde la educación media si
estoy de acuerdo vivo en un lugar donde
son conservadores las escuelas son
pequeñas ahora veo a la hermanita de mi
novio que cumplirá 12 años y algunas
niñas de su clase tienen sexo y ella
está en sexto grado la información que
dan en escuelas bebé
y adaptarse a cómo es ahora la sociedad
que sea el grado correcto la información
apropiada ya hablan de cosas como el
implante que es algo nuevo y de verdad
deberían comenzar a adaptarlo a como
somos ahora sí y como madres tenemos que
enseñarles todo a nuestros hijos desde
temprana edad pensé que mi mamá se
enojaría hay que ser abierta para que
ellos no no tengan miedo de hablarnos de
algo que es tan normal las relaciones
cambian luego de tener un hijo 321 ya
solía ser super extrovertida en
preparatoria en mis clases y demás
embarazarme y ser universitaria me hace
sentir más tímida al hablar en clases
porque siento que me juzgan más y tal
vez eso es algo que debo mejorar pero de
verdad que mi relación conmigo misma
cambio mucho sé qué nos pasa todas que
ves a tu bebé por primera vez y sientes
que tu vida cambia es como si los lentes
de niñez e ingenua por fin se caen y ves
el mundo desde ese nuevo punto de vista
acabas de crear vida
lloret de inmediato por mi mamá y por lo
mal que la trate antes de tener a mi
hija y lloré por mi hermana por como la
trate a las maestras todas esas cosas
que nos dijeron y sentíamos nuestras
tras tener a un hijo todo cambia ahora
cambia de opinión
cambias a quien más me costó decirle fue
a mi hermano porque somos gemelos y
justo ahora se prepara para el baile
este es último año y hace todas estas
cosas que yo ya no puedo no lo cambiaría
por nada pero decirle a él fue tan
difícil porque siempre fuimos unidos
tenemos la misma edad
amigos y ahora con mi hija que tiene
cuatro meses al llegar a casa del
trabajo es hola y me pide cargarla para
verla y eso es genial y me encanta así
que las relaciones mejoran también si
diría que es un hecho mi relación con mi
mamá cambió de forma drástica
antes de embarazarme si éramos unidas
pero no como ahora que compartimos esto
de la experiencia de la maternidad
porque creo que eso cambia todo que
ahora vemos todo lo que nuestros padres
y madres atravesaron lo que sintieron la
relación que ahora tengo con mi mamá ha
sido muy buena desde mi embarazo digo a
pesar de todo claro está decepcionado de
mí pero sí pero también está muy
emocionada por ser abuela y así es
el padre de mi bebé sigue involucrado en
nuestras vidas 321 ya
con mi esposo él está algo muy
involucrado casi me excluye a mí si
apenas puedo cargar a mi bebé cuando
está él fue planeado pero antes de todo
esto era mi prometido pues vengo de una
familia hispana y también está la
religión tienes que casarte antes de
tener sexo y tener un hijo así que
mantuvimos el secreto por tres meses
para asegurarnos que era seguro antes de
decirles a todos y nos enteramos del
embarazo un miércoles y nos casamos ese
sábado sí así que está bastante
importante quería preguntarte se habrían
casado si no te embarazadas lo habrían
hecho tan pronto quise decir sin el
embarazo lan ya vamos casarnos el mes
siguiente siguiendo queríamos casarnos
jóvenes solo
que él llegó un poco antes cuando yo
tenía 14 me embaracé y mi novio tenía 14
también y ya habíamos terminado cuando
me enteré del bebé y cuando le dije lo
que sucedía su primera reacción fue
enloquecer debes abortar aunque ya
tengas 3 meses y una de las cosas que
hizo fue decir que lo acosaba y bloquear
me hizo la prueba de paternidad él
decidió que yo era una cualquiera luego
de quedar embarazada incluso si él fue
el único con el que estuve después de
hacerse la prueba la corté introdujo
visitas ella tenía diez meses perdón
tenía diez meses y finalmente conoció a
su papá y
las visitas duraron un tiempo pero se ha
estado metiendo en peleas y no la ha
visto en un par de meses y no sé si
quiero que esté en su vida no creo que
sea saludable para ella a este punto
prefiero hacerlo sola que con él lo que
esperas de un novio lo que esperas de un
padre son cosas muy distintas totalmente
distintas y en especial porque los
hombres maduran más lento que las
si está el hecho de que los llevamos
nueve meses y estamos estamos con ellos
hasta tarde amamantando con fórmula lo
que sea estamos tan apegadas con estos
pequeños seres y los chicos tienen que
estar presentes para hacer eso a veces
no quieren estarlo simplemente no pueden
estar disfrutar su adolescencia en
especial porque aún lo son aún son niños
lo siguieron ir a fiestas quieren vivir
sus vidas y a veces es difícil el miedo
de todo chico es embarazar a su novia y
a veces se vuelve real animaría a otros
adolescentes a tener hijos 321 ya
no es que los animaría a que lo hagan no
iría a decirles embaraza te oye no
quieres un bebé y si es su decisión pues
que así sea si se puede prevenir si no
se sienten listos pues no lo hagan
porque
extraño dormir creo que es interesante
hablar de ti porque lo planeaste si
alguien me preguntara no le diría sí o
no
preguntaría si están listos y les diría
todo lo que deben considerar tienes
trabajo crees que estás listo estás
preparado algunas iluminaciones que
todos siempre piensan en las finanzas es
todo sobre tienes casa propia y lo demás
lo entiendo es extremadamente importante
pero mentalmente cada padre que he
conocido muestra lo difícil que ser
padre a cualquier edad así sin contar
que debes arreglártelas tú mismo y debes
arreglártelas con otro pequeño ser
humano hay una gran diferencia entre
apoyar a madres adolescentes y apoyar a
adolescentes a que sean madre o que son
cosas si es por ciento la gente se deja
llevar por lo que ven que comparten
instagram y saben todas las fotos que
subo ahí además de lo que publican 6
recta de no muy sigues como es ser madre
en realidad porque son las bonitas fotos
de mi hija con sus vestidos cosas así y
eso no muestra cómo es ser madre es
tener un bebé cambió mi vida para mejor
ya no es sólo hacer las cosas por mí
misma claro no puedo compararme con por
qué pero es tan simple como levantarme
para ir a mis clases pero tengo una
mayor motivación para cosas simples como
esa y luchar por algo mejor sin tiempos
difíciles se vuelven hermosos porque al
final de todo lo que llore antes de que
ella llegara por fin la tengo y ahora
tengo un futuro por el cual luchar estoy
aquí atravesando cosas difíciles y ella
me dio otra perspectiva y no se hizo más
fácil pero ella cambió todo lo malo y
bueno para mejor bien no quiero abrazos
son asombrosas esto no está bien
seguro de la luna
dónde están los bebés le gusta un
céntimo
[Música]
y el bebé tío la bebé me encanta cuando
contamos a tipos de personas muy
distintas y gente con la que tal vez
nunca interactúes o tener tu vida diaria
y así mostraremos sus historias en
especial los grupos con estereotipos
romper el estereotipo queremos combatir
lo digan en comentarios que otros
episodios quieren ver queremos humanizar
a todo el mundo todo el mundo volvemos
la próxima vivan intenso jubilee vive
intensamente